SHEP?
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS
OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
TONIGHT.
JOINING US NOW ALSO TO REACT
TO THE PRESIDENT'S OVAL
OFFICE ADDRESS TO THE
COUNTRY TONIGHT, SOUTH
CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
SENATOR GRAHAM YOU HAVE BEEN
AROUND CONGRESS BOTH IN 2006
YOU WERE AROUND WHEN THE
SECURE FENCE ACT WAS PASSED
TO BUILD 700 MILES OF WALL.
NEVER HAPPENED.
IN 2013, THEY ALLOCATED
$46 BILLION FOR BORDER
SECURITY.
8 BILLION TO BUILD AND
REPAIR.
AND REINFORCE BARRIERS AT
THE BORDER.
AND I'M LISTENING TO SENATOR
SCHUMER AND CONGRESSWOMAN
PELOSI SAY THIS IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
WOULD YOU SAY THAT TO POLICE
OFFICER SINGH'S FAMILY
TONIGHT OR PIERCE CORCORAN'S
MOM AND DAD THAT WERE ON
THIS PROGRAM LAST NIGHT OR
THE FAMILIES OF VICTIMS OF
4,000 HOMICIDES?
FAMILIES?
WOULD YOU SAY THIS IS
MANUFACTURED?
>> IT COULDN'T BE MORE REAL
TO THEM.
THIS IS THE MOST
PRESIDENTIAL I HAVE SEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT WAS COMPELLING AND
EVERYTHING HE SAID WAS TRUE.
ABOUT 30% OF THE 2200 MILES
OF BORDER HAS SOME FORM OF
BARRIER.
THERE ARE ALREADY WALLS
ALONG THE BORDER.
WE JUST NEED TO EXTEND THOSE
WALLS WHERE IT MAKES SENSE.
THE ONE THING WE HAVE IN
COMMON, AS A MEMBER OF THE
SENATE, SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, MINORITY LEADER OF
THE SENATE AND PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WE HAVE A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE GUARDING US
WITH GUNS.
IT'S PRETTY HARD TO GET IN
THE CAPITOL.
REALLY HARD TO GET IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
ALL THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING
I WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE MORE
SECURITY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT IS A CRISIS, SEAN.
I HAVE TRIED TO BE
REASONABLE AND PRACTICAL,
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
IMMIGRATION AND I'M
FLABBERGASTED TO HEAR FROM
MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE VOTED FOR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN BORDER SECURITY
MONEY THAT THIS IS
MANUFACTURED.
WAS IT MANUFACTURED WHEN
OBAMA WANTED THE MONEY?
NO.
WHY DID YOU GIVE THE MONEY
TO OBAMA AND BUSH IF IT WAS
A MANUFACTURED CRISIS?
>> Sean: I THINK IF YOU LOOK
HILLARY CLINTON SUPPORTED
IT, CHUCK SCHUMER SUPPORTED
IT, BIDEN SUPPORTED IT.
OBAMA SUPPORTED IT.
WE HAVE HAD IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS REALLY HIGH PROFILE
INCIDENCES, ONE IS OFFICER
SINGH AND THE OTHER IS THIS
YOUNG MAN, HIS PARENTS WERE
ON THIS SHOW LAST NIGHT.
PIERCE CORCORAN DIED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT KILLED HIM IN A
DRUNK DRIVING ACCIDENT.
AND THE QUESTION HERE IS
WHEN YOU ADD TO THAT THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING, AND YOU ADD TO
THAT THE VIOLENCE AT THE
BORDER.
AND LET'S ASSUME 98% OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER,
WHICH I BELIEVE, ARE PEOPLE
THAT WANT MORE FREEDOM AND
OPPORTUNITY.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: WE HAVE GOT TO ASK
OURSELVES, IF WE LOSE 4,000
LIVES IN A TWO-YEAR PERIOD,
IS THAT A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS?
>> TO MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS,
HOW MANY CARAVANS HAVE TO
RUSH THE BORDER UNTIL YOU
BELIEVE WE HAVE A PROBLEM?
WE HAVE 300,000 PEOPLE
WAITING FOR ASYLUM CLAIMS TO
BE ADJUDICATED.
WE HAVE 11,000 UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS FROM CENTRAL AMERICA.
IT COSTS US $750 A DAY TO
HOUSE THEM.
ONLY GOD KNOW WHAT IS THEY
GO THROUGH TO GET HERE.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS ON
THE RISE BECAUSE OUR
POLICIES ARE ATTRACTING
PEOPLE HERE.
EVERY DEMOCRAT, YOU HEARD
FROM TONIGHT, HAS VOTED FOR
BORDER SECURITY.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO TRUMP
THEY SAY NO.
SO NANCY PELOSI SAYS END THE
SHUTDOWN.
DONALD TRUMP SAYS SECURE THE
BORDER.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
LET'S SECURE THE BORDER THEN
END THE SHUTDOWN.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU,
SENATOR, IT SEEMS TO COME
DOWN TO THEIR ARGUMENT IS
AND I KNOW IT IS
INCONVENIENT FOR THOSE
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES.
I ACKNOWLEDGE AND I CAN
SYMPATHIZE WITH THEM.
I KNOW THEIR CHECKS ARE
GOING TO BE DELAYED IN SOME
CASES.
IT'S A PARTIAL GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
ESSENTIAL SERVICES ARE UP
AND RUNNING AND THAT
CONSTITUTES WHAT TWO THIRDS
TO 70% OF THE GOVERNMENT
STAYS HOPE OPEN.
I DO WANT THESE PEOPLE
FURLOUGHED TO GET
BACK-MONEY, ET CETERA.
THE POINT IS THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T TAKE THE STAND HERE,
FULLY, DO YOU SEE ANY OTHER
PATH THAT HE CAN USE THAT HE
WILL GET THE MONEY TO STOP
THE CRIMES FROM HAPPENING ON
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, THE
DRUG TRAFFICKING, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, SOME CRIMINAL
ELEMENTS THAT WANT TO CROSS
OVER OUR BORDER?
>> I HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH
THIS SINCE 2006.
THIS IS THE BEST CHANCE I
HAVE SEEN TO GET A DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT MADE A
COMPELLING CASE TONIGHT FOR
MORE BORDER SECURITY.
AND I THINK HE IS RIGHT TO
ASK FOR MORE MONEY TO SECURE
OUR BORDER.
AS TO THE GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES, I'M SORRY YOU ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS MESS.
BUT YOU WILL GET YOUR BACK
PAY.
YOU ARE GOING TO BE FULLY
COMPENSATED.
MISS SINGH IS NOT GOING TO
GET HER HUSBAND BACK.
TO SAY ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES FROM
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, YOUR
LOVED ONES ARE NOT COMING
BACK.
SO I AM BOUND AND DETERMINED
TO SEE THIS THING THROUGH.
THERE SHOULD BE A DEAL WHERE
WE SECURE THE BORDER, GIVE
THE PRESIDENT THE WALL MONEY
HE NEEDS, AND TRY TO FIX
OTHER PROBLEMS LIKE TPS
REFORM AND MAYBE DO
SOMETHING FOR THE DACA
POPULATION.
THERE IS A DEAL TO BE HAD
HERE.
BUT IT'S HARD TO GET A DEAL
WHEN PEOPLE YOU'RE DEALING
WITH CALL YOU A RACIST
BECAUSE YOU WANT A BORDER
SECURITY WALL.
GIVE YOU A DOLLAR AND SAY
THAT'S ENOUGH.
ACCUSE BORDER PATROL AGENTS
OF GASSING CHILDREN WHEN
MOBS RUN TOWARD OUR BORDER.
WE'RE DEALING WITH PRETTY
RADICAL PEOPLE HERE AND
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO GET A
DEAL UNTIL THE RADICALS ARE
SET TO THE SIDE AND WE GET
REASONABLE PEOPLE TO DEAL
WITH.
>> Sean: ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING IT WAS SUPPORTED
BY DEMOCRATS IN THE PAST.
YOU ARE MAKING A GOOD POINT
HERE.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO, AS WE
KNOW, ACCOMPLISH ICE, KAMALA
HARRIS ACTUALLY SAID TO THE
FORMER HEAD OF ICE TOM HOMAN
SUGGESTED THAT WELL YOU KNOW
THERE IS A PERCEPTION THAT
ICE IS AT LEAST IN PEOPLE'S
MINDS PERCEIVED AS THE KU
KLUX KLAN.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: I WAS PRETTY
STUNNED WE WOULD TALK ABOUT
BRAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
WAY.
WE ALSO WATCHED THESE
OFFICERS GET PELTED WITH
ROCKS AND BOTTLES ON TWO
OCCASIONS DURING THE MIGRANT
CARAVAN AND ON NEW YEAR'S
EVE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS:
THIS IS THE QUESTION I THINK
WE NEED TO ASK TONIGHT.
WILL THE WALL WORK?
IN HUMA, ARIZONA, THE
SHERIFF SAID IT WORKS.
IT WORKS.
EVERY TIME IT'S BEEN TRIED.
>> WELL, IT WORKS IN ISRAEL.
I CAN TELL YOU, I HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH BORDER SECURITY
ISSUES FOR 10 YEARS, PLUS.
EVERY TIME WE BUILD A
PHYSICAL BARRIER THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING GOES DOWN.
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS GO DOWN.
THERE ARE SOME PLACES YOU
DON'T NEED A PHYSICAL
BARRIER BUT THERE IS
700 MILES OF FENCING HAS
BEEN AUTHORIZED SINCE 2006.
WE JUST WANT TO BUILD WHAT
WE HAVE ALREADY AGREED TO
DO.
AND SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS
WALLS WORK.
BUT YOU ARE DEALING WITH A
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO SEE
THEIR GOVERNMENT AS THE
PROBLEM.
THEY SEE THE BORDER PATROL
AGENT AS THE PROBLEM, NOT
THE MOB.
THEY SEE THE ICE AGENT AS
THE PROBLEM, NOT THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT THEY ARE TRYING TO
GO AFTER.
THEY SEE WALLS AS ALREADY
EXIST AS IMMORAL.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK IS
IMMORAL, IS TO ACCUSE PEOPLE
OF TRYING TO DEFEND THE
NATION, HONESTLY AND WORKING
HARD AND PUTTING THEIR LIVES
AT RISK OF BEING THE PROBLEM
AND NOT THE COYOTE, NOT THE
DRUG DEALER, NOT THE
TERRORIST.
SO, IF DEMOCRATS WANT A
FIGHT, THEY ARE GOING TO GET
ONE.
IF THEY WANT TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM, WE WILL DO THAT
TOO.
>> Sean: I WANT TO KNOW
WHERE YOUR FELLOW REPUBLICAN
SENATORS STAND HERE.
BECAUSE IF THE ARGUMENT OF
THE DEMOCRATS IS THIS IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS, WELL,
THAT GOES AGAINST THE NUMBER
OF HOMICIDES AND THAT
TWO-YEAR PERIOD AND SEX
OFFENSES THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE IN THAT TWO-YEAR
PERIOD AND VIOLENT ACTS
AGAINST AMERICANS IN THAT
TWO-YEAR PERIOD.
THEN THE DRUG AND THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THE QUESTION IS HERE, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ON THE ONE
HAND WE WILL HAVE SOME
PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR OUR
GOVERNMENT THAT ARE
INCONVENIENCED.
I AM SYMPATHETIC TO THAT.
>> I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT,
YES.
ME TOO.
>> Sean: I'M ALSO
SYMPATHETIC TO THE PARENTS
THAT WERE ON THIS PROGRAM
LAST NIGHT.
I'M SYMPATHETIC OF THE
5-MONTH-OLD LITTLE BOY OF A
POLICE OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WILL NEVER SEE HIS
FATHER FOR THE REST OF HIS
LIFE.
AND I'M SYMPATHETIC TO THE
VICTIMS OF CRIME.
ARE YOUR FELLOW MUCKS
WILLING
-LLING
--LING
--RENG
--REPUBLICANS WILLING TO SAY
LIFE AND DEATH IS MORE
IMPORTANCE THAN A
PAYCHECK -- -- HOPE MOST
WILL REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRATS
YOU VOTED FOR $25 BILLION
FOR BORDER SECURITY FUNDING
IN FEBRUARY OF 2018.
IF IT WAS NOT -- IF IT'S A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS, ARE
SENATOR SCHUMER, SPEAKER
PELOSI, WHY DID YOU VOTE FOR
BORDER SECURITY PACKAGE LESS
THAN A YEAR AGO THAT HAD
$25 BILLION FOR BORDER
SECURITY, INCLUDING WALL
MONEY.
TO SAY MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES.
THIS IS THE BEST CHANCE WE
WILL EVER HAVE TO HELP
PRESIDENT TRUMP GET BORDER
BORDER WALL FUNDING, STEEL
BARRIER FUNDING AND AT THE
SAME TIME FIX THE LOOPHOLES.
THE ONLY WAY WE LOSE IS TO
GIVE IN.
IF WE WILL STAND FIRM -- PUT
DEALS ON THE TABLE THAT MAKE
SENSE, WE WILL WIN THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
BUT IF WE UNDERCUT THE
PRESIDENT, THAT'S THE END OF
HIS PRESIDENCY AND THE END
OF OUR PARTY.
AND WE DESERVE TO BE
PUNISHED IF WE GIVE IN NOW.
>> Sean: IN OTHER WORDS, AS
LONG AS IT TAKES, YOU
BELIEVE YOU AND YOUR FELLOW
SENATORS ARE WILLING TO STAY
AND FIGHT TO STOP DRUGS,
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, AND
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY FROM THE
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE
THAT CROSS OUR BORDER
BECAUSE IT'S UNSAFE AND NOT
SECURED?
>> BEFORE THE END OF THIS
WEEK I INTEND TO PUT
LEGISLATION TOGETHER THAT
HAS WALL FUNDING LIKE THE
PRESIDENT HAS REQUESTED AND
ARGUE THAT WE VOTED FOR THE
SAME THING IN THE PAST
BEFORE HE WAS PRESIDENT.
AND I INTEND TO PUT LEGAL
REFORMS ON THE TABLE THAT WE
HAVE ALL VOTED FOR.
I INTEND TO HELP THE TPS
POPULATION ABOUT 400,000
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOSE
THEIR LEGAL STATUS.
I'M WILLING TO ENTERTAIN
LEGAL STATUS FOR THE DREAM
ACT POPULATION THAT WE HAVE
ALL VOTED FOR.
SO WHAT A AM I GOING TO DO?
I'M GOING TO TAKE BILLS WE
HAVE ALL VOTED FOR AND SEE
IF THEY CAN BE VOTED FOR
UNDER TRUMP.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT THE
POLICY.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT MY
DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS DON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT PRESIDENT